and look look nakamura is like it seems
like he just wants to go don't do it
not going more down than 59 959
nakamura has experienced in this line
he's played this with both colors around
50 times so he knows the moves exactly
well what can i say when i said that
it's going to be less than an hour i was
frightened
extremely generous about 10 minutes was
the question
yeah rising his eyebrows queen e4
the arbiter oh my
well
this was a funny thing
let's see what the arbiter says maybe
says no you can't do it you can imagine
that the argument will argue no no no
let's see that they're queenie for did
you did you make it enough moves let's
check it
please keep doing it to move 40.
and some people are smiling behind the
camera as i see nakamura is like
fantastic first game is finished already
time to go do the recap
all right chad i prepared a solid line
of the berlin today i wonder what one
shouldn't play the most critical
what nakamura will be streaming and
making the recap about this game
wow but
can't really blame anybody no jan is
doing what he needs to do to win his
tournament hikaru plays his repertoire
he always plays and if white wants to
draw at this level